turning to the war in ukraine there are
fierce battles underway in the eastern
part of the country ukrainian soldiers
are trying to regain more ground as they
try to push russian soldiers farther
away from the city of park keith
meanwhile in the south the mayor mariupl
says the evacuation routes for civilians
have been cut off deborah patta is in
ukraine deborah good morning
good morning the family members of those
men trapped in that steel mill in mario
paul are growing increasingly desperate
they want the world to intervene before
it's too late
time is running out for the ukrainian
regiment living under relentless russian
bombing
for over two months it's hard to imagine
how anyone has survived
the government has offered to swap the
badly injured soldiers for russian
prisoners of war the fighters are close
to starving many with amputated limbs
doctors operating without medical
supplies
lilia stupina says the world is not
doing enough to rescue these fighters
including her husband andrei whom she
met in high school i know that love at
first sight no
frankly speaking
but now it's a fierce and passionate
love of course
i will take a gun and
go to maripo by myself
you'll take a gun and go to mario
i will do everything to save him
in the east and south the fighting has
not lit up civilians forced to flee
they've witnessed horrors no one should
ever have to see and this teenager
already wise beyond his years
the young have no future he says the old
have no past
in her kiev it's a game of cat and moss
the danger is never far away
ukrainian forces rush to take cover
it's a close call
but this time no one is hurt
village by village they are pushing
russian troops back towards the border
as they retreat a trail of death and
destruction in their wake
like so many left behind 66 year old
raisa cannot believe it's come to this
she's lost her home her hope
she's lost everything
there's been a development on the world
stage finland's leaders want to apply
for nato membership it's worth noting
finland shares a border with russia gail
yeah
that is worth noting i instruct deborah
what you said the young have no future
the old have no past boy thank you very
much